bioinformatics for infectious diseases
is an online training program designed
to introduce students clinicians and
researchers
to the role and the applications of
bioinformatics
in the study of pathogenic
microorganisms and their interaction
with the host
which lead to and enable human disease
by passing through the layers of immune
defenses and hijacking whole cell
machinery to replicate
these microorganisms wreak havoc
seemingly just to replicate to learn
about their strategies
tools and tactics we can study the
sequences of genomic code
enabled by easily accessible and highly
accurate
next generation sequencing technologies
genomics and bioinformatics have
contributed immensely to our
understanding of
infectious diseases in fact
bioinformatics tools
databases and analytical software are
used regularly to study disease
pathogenesis mechanism of interaction
between the pathogen and the host
the emergence and spread of drug
resistance and the variability of host
immune responses
this information is becoming widely
accessible
millions of sequences and hundreds of
thousands of full
genomes are available on repositories
hosted
by the national center of biotechnology
information
and other databases like the join genome
institute's
integrated microbial genomes database
these databases
are growing in size at an exponential
speed
in fact as the prices of genomic
sequencing
continue to fall a much deeper
understanding is emerging of genomic
variability and the complexity
at which microorganisms interact and
affect the host that they inhibit
we know today that all microorganisms
live in
complex communities and not as just
individual and isolated genomes as
previously was thought
these stable communities where competing
microbes
establish a shared environment are an
essential component
of our own immune system the size of the
mammalian birom is actually not
known exactly although our own cells are
outnumbered about 10-fold by our
bacterial microbiome
the number of viruses may be 10-fold
higher still
human feces alone contain approximately
10 to the 8th
to 10 to the 9th viruses per gram
additionally the mammalian viral is
continuously
updated through rapid evolution of
viruses and through
exposure to viruses in the environment
or in other
mammals in this program we will focus on
data analysis tools that enable
researchers to extract
meaningful insights from viral and
bacterial
sequencing data to understand the
various pressures
interactions and changes associated with
infectious diseases there are three
kinds of sequencing approaches
that we will learn about that allow us
to sample
isolated individuals via targeted
sequencing
whole dna or rna sequencing as well as
shotgun metagenomic sequencing of
hypervariable regions such as the 16s
ribosomal rna gene in bacteria
these methods allow us to study
individual pathogens
or study whole microbial communities in
their native composition
to understand how they can characterize
diseases
and their spread we will look
at phylogenetic tree reconstruction to
understand the spread of west african
ebola virus outbreak in 2014-2016
study stars cove two genomes and cell
responses
as well as see how the microbiome is
associated with disease
and drug response the challenge with
such
data is that the shotgun approach that
produces
millions of reads per sample requires a
reference with which we can identify the
position
the abundance and variation of genomic
sequences
from a single or multiple references
in this program we will focus on
processing
and analysis methods that are used to
characterize
and analyze genomic and transcriptomic
data
these methods will include hands-on
exercises on the
interactive tbion4 platform which
provides a simple and intuitive
interface for
processing analysis and even machine
learning methods for multi-omics data
by allowing all of the methods that we
discussed to be run on the platform
this will lower the barrier and enable
even those that do not have the
technical background
to effectively participate in this
program
you will see how important nucleotide
level variation can be studied
from the codon level to study variant
types
for single and multi-nucleotide
variation
where we will incorporate common
considerations for accurate
discrimination between statistically
significant and
insignificant variants at the read level
as well as advanced methods to
deconvolute
such coverage variation in large data
sets
we will also discuss methods for
differential variant calling
that can help us compare multiple
samples for association with phenotype
defined by a group of samples ultimately
we will find
the way that such studies can help
explain captured data from the point of
view of a mechanistic model of
replication
immune response and disease pathogenesis
that all contribute to the variability
between
and within each sample based on bulk
and single cell data we will also
reconstruct phylogenetic trees tracing
how the observed species
that we capture in our data can
represent a common source
origin and even study the evolutionary
progression
correlating with time that separates
multiple samples
in a given study we will use the example
of viral
outbreaks like the ebola virus epidemic
of 2014 to 2016
as well as the ongoing covenanting
pandemic
we will also rely on easy to use tools
for multiple sequence alignment and
annotation
of source code 2 data sets which will
show us the organization of elements in
the viral genomes
that allow us to replicate key findings
in top
peer-reviewed journals on the emergence
and evolution
of source code 2 pandemic for example
we will look at the variability of
nucleotide sequences between all the
coronaviruses to find specific genes or
even regions that are less conserved
and discuss their functional
significance we will then go beyond the
sequence itself
to understand where 3d structures and
transcriptomic data
can also help us understand the
implications of genomic variants
we identify at the interaction between
host and viral proteins
as we will see similarity scores will
allow us to find
special portions of the genome that are
more variable than
others and we will use this information
to map and find those portions on the
protein structures
characterizing the various functional
elements of these proteins
that we want to understand from a
biological standpoint
in fact we will learn how to build
models that allow us to place
all of the proteins involved in an
interaction
and study how they might be changing
as a result of variation that we found
in the sequencing data
we will also see how the significance of
ebola virus
variants has led to a lot of
considerations
around antiviral and vaccine design
and discover how such methods are used
for the study of tuberculosis and other
bacterial infections giving rise
to a better understanding of multi-drug
resistant
strains of tuberculosis and malaria
but these are just examples ultimately
you will be able to
read through publications finding source
data
as well as understanding the methods
described
so that you can combine novel data and
methods
introducing a project of your own that
you will be
able to present to other participants of
this program
the goal of omics logic programs is to
provide
training and bioinformatics enabling
independent research
guided by mentors and peer example
to develop a growing community with
shared passion
for data-driven research and an
appreciation of citizen science that is
accurate and reproducible and to enable
students clinicians
and faculty of all backgrounds to
develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology in life
and data sciences so we invite you to
join
this program on bioinformatics for
infectious diseases where we will talk
about
different types of pathogens and the
diseases that they cause
to learn about analysis approaches and
the leverage of bioinformatics to study
such pathogens
using curated projects and data sets and
applying tools that are easy to use for
even a novice
in this program we will combine online
sessions
self-guided study materials as well as
practical assignments for an immersive
and hands-on experience